Lisa Marie Presley's sudden passing deeply
affected the singer's friends, family, and fans.
But ex-husband Nicolas Cage had a very specific
thought to share regarding his former partner.
The untimely and surprising
death of Lisa Marie Presley,
the daughter of the legendary musician Elvis, has
shaken many in the entertainment world. Presley
died at the age of 54 on January 12 after
suffering from a reported cardiac arrest,
with her mother, Priscilla Presley, releasing a
statement that announced her passing. She added
that Lisa was the most loving, passionate,
and strongest woman that she had ever known.
"From beginning life as one of the most
famous babies ever to becoming a fiercely
loving mother in her own right, Lisa
Marie Presley saw herself as a rebel."
Other celebrities and friends also took to
social media to mourn her passing.
John Travolta posted on Instagram,
Similarly, Pink also shared an image of
Presley and herself on Instagram and wrote,
Unsurprisingly, Nicolas Cage also shared his
absolute shock and dismay at this tragic news,
as the "National Treasure" star
and Presley were married in 2002.
Nicolas Cage and Lisa Marie Presley
had a very tumultuous relationship,
which was often highlighted by the
media. Despite their issues 20 years ago,
Cage still remembers his ex-wife
fondly. The Hollywood Reporter
shared a statement from the actor on
his ex-wife's passing, which read,
It seems as if Cage still cares deeply for his
former partner, and his sentiments reveal that
he had a deep and profound understanding
of Presley's most recent heart-breaking
struggles. Presley's son Benjamin died in
2020 and left her understandably devastated.
Cage and Presley had a whirlwind of a romance in
the early 2000s. Both had been married before,
and they met at a birthday party for the
famous rocker Johnny Ramone in October 2000,
with the two announcing their relationship in
May of the following year. Cage and Presley were
married on August 16, 2002, but divorce papers
were filed shortly after on November 25 of the
same year. This brief romance had quite an impact
on the two, with Presley saying at the time,
Lisa Marie Presley's words
definitely held some weight,
as the couple had some well-publicized
issues. During one famous fight,
the two were in such a heated argument that
Presley supposedly tossed her $65,000 ring
into the ocean. Cage explained their
short-lived relationship by saying,
He added,
Speaking with Access Hollywood, Presley clarified
her relationship troubles with Cage by saying,